bonjour à toutes et à tous je vous
propose que nous commencions
nous avons donc aujourd'hui une
plusieurs auditions et nous avons le
plaisir de vous accueillir pour
commencer Mesdames et Messieurs les
représentants de la CNIL Monsieur le
Secrétaire général Monsieur le Directeur
des technologies d'innovation et Madame
la Directrice de la protection des
droits et des sanctions
nous débutons donc avec vous la CNIL et
le régulateur de régulateur des données
personnelles c'est à ce titre que vous
nous intéressez
je vous propose que nous commençons
nous avons donc aujourd'hui une
plusieurs auditions et nous avons le
plaisir de vous accueillir pour
commencer Mesdames et Messieurs les
représentants de la CNIL Monsieur le
Secrétaire général Monsieur le Directeur
des technologies d'innovation et Madame
la Directrice de la protection des
droits et des sanctions
nous débutons donc avec vous la CNIL et
le régulateur de régulateur des données
personnelles c'est à ce titre que vous
nous intéressez du fait de cette
compétence pour mener nos travaux vous
avez été semble-t-il le premier
régulateur français vous allez nous
préciser cela à avoir sanctionné Tik Tok
en décembre dernier mais la décision ne
semble avoir concerné que le
fonctionnement de son site web et non
son application peut-être pourrait vous
en expliquer les raisons et nous dire où
en est cette procédure ça nous intéresse
particulièrement parce que le site web
n'est pas forcément sur le téléphone et
visiblement la question du téléphone
concentre un certain nombre de sujets
à l'occasion d'une rencontre organisée
par le directeur du pôle d'expertise de
la régulation numérique le pérenne que
nous sommes allés voir en fin de semaine
dernière nous avons été nombreux à avoir
été frappés par l'ampleur des données
collectées sur nos téléphones par ce
type d'application de manière générale
ces données dans certaines semblent
triviales peuvent par recoupement
parfaitement identifiés d'utilisateur et
même s'agissant de Tik Tok ou autre où
nous le direz peut-être dresser un
profil psychologique de celui-ci selon
les termes employés par le chercheur
Marc Fadoul nous serions intéressés de
comprendre comment la CNIL s'organise
pour contrôler ses applications y a-t-il
une particularité sur le contrôle de Tik
Tok et par ailleurs que vous nous
précisiez votre rôle spécifique
vis-à-vis de ce groupe au ramification
internationale au regard de celui
d'autres autorités de contrôle
européenne et on parle notamment de la
data protection commission irlandaise je
me dois devoir appeler que cette
audition est captée retransmise en
direct sur le site du Sénat et avant de
vous laisser la parole à tous les trois
pour un exposé liminaire d'une quinzaine
de minutes si vous l'aviez prévu ainsi
puis on aura une heure et quart au
global pour laisser le temps aux
questions je me dois de procéder au
formalités d'usage pour les commissions
d'enquête et doit ainsi vous rappeler
qu'un faux témoignage avant notre
commission d'enquête et passible des
peines prévues aux articles 434 13 14 et
15 du code pénal et je vous invite à
prêter serment de dire toute la vérité
rien que la vérité en levant la main
droite et en disant je le jure
je le jure
je jure
merci bien je ne sais pas qui prend la
main pour l'exposé luminaire peut-être
vous monsieur ce cadre général merci
beaucoup monsieur le Président merci à
la commission d'enquête d'avoir
effectivement proposé à la à la CNIL de
venir parler du sujet qui vous intéresse
je
représente la présidente de la CNIL qui
ne peut pas être là aujourd'hui elle
était à Washington mais
qui évidemment à votre disposition s'il
fallait prolonger ses débats par le
questionnaire écrit d'abord puis
évidemment à l'oral si si nécessaire
un point également que je tiens à
souligner comme vous l'avez dit le
l'audition est publique donc pour un
certain nombre des réponses il est
possible
que nous vous opposions le caractère
confidentiel de l'instruction notamment
si nous parlons des dossiers que nous
gérons en coopération avec la difficile
autorité irlandaise nous vous indiquons
évidemment des éléments plus précis dans
le questionnaire que nous vous enverrons
écrit et encore une fois l'échange peut
être prolongé si vous le souhaitez à un
moment de vos travaux par une audition à
huis clos mais donc voilà c'est pour
prévenir que sur certains éléments on
indiquera cette confidentialité et si
vous permettez quand c'est confidentiels
on préfère vous nous le disiez et puis
en insiste pas et comment vous puissiez
nous donner ou alors si vous ne pouvez
pas nous le dire publiquement que vous
nous fassiez savoir rapidement par la
suite mais qu'au moins qu'on sache ce
qui relève du confidentiel ou ce qui
peut relever du fait de ne pas répondre
ou l'oubli je le dis par rapport à
d'autres auditions qu'on a eu on préfère
autant que vous nous opposiez les choses
clairement comme ça
que je commence par ce point j'ai bien
compris que ça allait arriver alors je
voudrais pour faire ce propos liminaire
balayé rapidement quatre points d'abord
quelles sont les compétences de la CNIL
par rapport à Tik Tok et qu'est-ce
qu'elles ne sont pas aussi ensuite
balayer rapidement un peu peut-être les
spécificités ou non de Tik Tok par
rapport au traitement des données
personnelles d'utilisateurs sur ce qui
les communes appelé un réseau social
ensuite
aborder rapidement la question des
transferts de données personnelles en
dehors de l'Union Européenne et puis
peut-être à un mot mais rapidement en
conclusion sur la question de la
sécurité de la cybersécurité des
administrations et du téléchargement ou
pas de Tik Tok alors d'abord les
compétences de la CNIL la CNIL et
compétente vis-à-vis de Tik Tok pour
deux textes deux ensembles de
réglementation le rgpd donc un ensemble
important avec de très nombreuses règles
sur les données personnelles et leurs
traitement et un texte beaucoup plus
spécifique la directive epryvaci pour ce
qui est de la règle de protection des
terminaux c'est à dire du fait qu'on ne
peut lire ou écrire dans votre terminal
avec l'application TikTok qu'avec votre
consentement sauf si c'est nécessaire au
fonctionnement du service que vous avez
demandé la CNIL n'est donc c'est déjà
assez large et la CNIL n'est pas
compétente pour tout un tas de de
législation plus spécifique sur le
caractère approprié ou non des contenus
haineux des informations etc etc même si
évidemment c'est toujours en lien avec
la licéité du traitement de en général
mais avec ce type de traitement la CNIL
serait compétente de raisonnement la
clinique très compétente pour tout donc
voilà c'est pour signaler que nous
arrêtons au traitement de la de la
donnée alors nous étions compétents nous
étions compétents pour Tik Tok sur ces
deux séries de dispositions et des
contrôles ont été lancés début 2020 à la
fois sur l'application le site par
questionnaire par voie écrite etc le
rgpd prévoit le règlement général sur la
protection des données prévoit un
système de guichet unique ce guichet
unique fait que des entreprises des
groupes qui ont une activité à l'échelle
de l'Union européenne n'ont qu'une seule
CNIL qu'une seule autorité de protection
des données comme intermédiaires
généralement au lieu de leur siège le
règlement parle d'établissement
principal en juillet 2020 mi-2020 à peu
près Tik Tok a créé un établissement
principal un système d'établissement
principal en Irlande en réorganisant la
manière dont était régie c'est
traitements je te laisserai madame
Kieffer sur ce point après le propos
liminaire et c'est maintenant Tik Tok
Irlande et TikTok UK qui sont
correspondables d'un grand nombre des
traitements de TikTok et ces Tik Tok
Irlande et donc l'autorité irlandaise
qui est compétente à partir du moment où
nous a été opposé d'une certaine façon
cette structuration qui est que TikTok
tout à fait légitime à faire nous sommes
retrouvés incompétents sur les
procédures que nous avions lancées à
l'exception de ce qui pourrait toucher
la directive IP priver ici parce que
pour une raison un peu compliqué
d'articulation des textes pour cette
règle spécifique là chaque pays demeure
compétent pour les utilisateurs les
terminaux sur son territoire donc à
partir de ce moment-là nous avons
transféré les plaintes que nous avions
les contrôles les constats les
investigations les interrogations rien
de tout ça n'était abouti
la difficile et depuis lors nous sommes
dans un mécanisme de coopération avec
l'autorité irlandaise c'est une
coopération je tiens à le souligner ou à
la demande express assistante de la
présidente de la CNIL nous avons été en
contact régulier avec nos homologues
irlandais pour leur demander où en était
les procédures où on était les constats
comment cela avancer
nous ne sommes pas les seuls en Europe
mais en tout cas voilà on avait fait des
constats des contrôles on leur a passé
ces éléments et on est régulièrement
revenu vers eux en leur demandant que
les procédures puissent aboutir sous une
instruction qui relève de leur
responsabilité
irlandaise et donc ça c'est c'est public
sous contrôle encore une fois de Karine
a donc deux instructions en cours une de
ces instructions à donner lieu à un
projet ça a été annoncé qui a été envoyé
au Comité européen de la protection des
données qui concerne notamment
les questions du traitement des données
des mineurs le contenu du projet n'est
pas public en revanche il passe
maintenant dans le mécanisme de
coopération qui est prévue par le
règlement général à la protection des
données et on peut espérer une décision
je l'espère au milieu de l'année 2023
une autre procédure est toujours en
cours et là il n'y a pas de projet de
décision qui était
envoyer donc
nous n'avons pas vu ce projet devrait je
dis bien devrait inclure la question des
transferts sur laquelle nous avions
particulièrement demandé à l'autorité
irlandaise de regarder des derniers
contacts que nous avons eu avec nos
homologues irlandais nous espérons mais
là encore pour l'instant nous n'avons
pas qu'un projet un projet soit circuler
partager au Comité européen la
protection des données vers le milieu de
l'année 2023 déclenchant ensuite le
système de coopération donc une décision
définitive et espérée vers le milieu de
l'année pour le premier dossier une un
projet de décision à adopter en
coopération de l'autre côté
voilà pour vous rappeler donc quel était
notre compétence sur la compétence IP
privacy comme vous l'avez indiqué nous
avons pris une sanction la CNIL la
formation restreinte d'une sanction de 5
millions sur des questions tout à fait
classique qui ne sont pas spécifiques à
TikTok de cookies de avec les interfaces
de demande de consentement de cookies
uniquement sur le site web qui comme
vous l'avez constaté comme comme vous
l'avez rappelé au début n'est pas le
principal vecteur pour pour
l'application
TikTok cette procédure s'est inscrite
dans le cadre d'un plan beaucoup
beaucoup plus général mené depuis 2020
par la par la CNIL sur l'ensemble des
sites internet et le recueil des cookies
TikTok n'étant qu'un un des acteurs
visés par ces procédures parmi de
nombreux autres et dans un second temps
la CNIL avait annoncé ce chaînage le des
contrôles similaires si on fait sur les
applications de téléphone la le
l'exercice sur les sites internet c'est
achevé au début de l'année 2023 et donc
nous avons des tas de procédures en
cours sur les applications
je signale que le contrôle et le
fonctionnement d'une application même si
c'est les mêmes règles pour les pour les
cookies c'est en réalité techniquement
très différent des sites Web qui
expliquent qu'on ait fait les choses en
deux temps alors un deuxième temps
maintenant de ces quelques propos
liminaires pour vous dire que s'agissant
du traitement des données le site
l'application TikTok le réseau social
TikTok présente des problématiques
largement classiques et communes à
beaucoup de réseaux sociaux même si
elles sont par certains aspects
amplifiés comme les autres réseaux
sociaux ce type de d'outils de
dispositif collectes un nombre
impressionnant de données personnelles
sur ces utilisateurs d'une très grande
finesse d'une très grande
intrusivité c'est peut-être pas le mot
puisque l'utilisateur les partages
volontairement mais ce qui est possible
de savoir sur l'utilisateur à travers ce
qu'il dit ce qu'il partage ce qu'il
regarde son comportement sur une
application tel que Facebook snapchat
Instagram et Tik Tok et absolument
impressionnant c'est d'ailleurs pour ça
que ces données intéresse autant les
publicitaires les scientifiques etc et
donc Tik Tok n'échappe pas à la règle
peut-être que Tik Tok et va dans une
finesse de données qui est pour certains
types de données pas forcément toutes
mais pour certains types de données
encore plus grandes que pour d'autres
réseaux notamment le temps de visionnage
comme vous le savez est extrêmement
rapide
l'appréhension et le le
du comportement de l'utilisateur de son
interaction avec le réseau social semble
aller dans un grand degré de finesse
c'est évidemment en lien avec ce fameux
algorithme de
propositions pour toi de vidéo
particulière deuxième point
deux caractéristiques quand même assez
forte de de Tik Tok la rapidité et la
jeunesse la
du visionnage inclut une rapidité de
l'enrichissement
du profilage des données tout ça
multiplié par pour vous avez vu les
statistiques d'une consommation très
élevée chez les chez les plus jeunes
publics et ça se combine évidemment avec
le fait que c'est un réseau social qui a
beaucoup de succès chez les plus jeunes
et donc les plus jeunes présentent des
vulnaries vulnérabilités particulières
vont être moins prudents dans l'usage de
leur donner personnelle vont être
beaucoup moins ça on le voit tout à fait
Karine Kieffer pour y revenir sur les
aspects plaintes connaissent beaucoup
moins leurs droits donc vont moins être
agiles pour pouvoir rattraper quelque
chose qui est en train de mal partir
pour effacer les données ou des choses
comme ça porter plainte à la CNIL etc
voilà et donc les risques qui sont liés
à ce traitement de données à caractère
personnel sont des risques qui sont en
grande partie classique et connue de
toute la littérature sur ce type de
traitement de données ils sont peut-être
pour certains amplifier du fait du
fonctionnement particulier de Tik Tok
sont des risques évidemment sur la vie
privée la visibilité de ce que vous
mettez sur le réseau social ou de ce que
vous partagez de ce que vous dites de
vos opinions politiques religieuses etc
vous n'avez pas toujours conscience
notamment pour les plus jeunes que c'est
visible que ça laisse des traces etc il
y a un ciblage qui repose sur le
consentement dans le paramétrage de de
l'application mais qui est évidemment
consubstantielle ciblage sur les vidéos
ciblesses sur les publicités pour le
consentement sur les vidéos c'est le
fonctionnement même ça c'est pas sur le
consentement et et qui parfois dépassent
qui va dépasser ce que vous pouviez
avoir
anticiper comme comme capacité de de
profilage il y a des risques sur
l'utilisation des données sensibles dont
l'utilisateur n'a pas forcément
conscience qu'il les révèle à travers
son comportement à travers le fait que
il va avoir tel ou tel type de
comportement avec d'utilisation du
réseau social un jour d'une fête
religieuse par exemple ou d'une
manifestation politique des choses
peuvent en être inférées et enfin ce que
nous appel ons parfois la bulle de
filtrage l'algorithme en vous proposant
des choses qui correspondent à ce qui
est censé le plus vous intéresser par
rapport à ce que vous avez déjà vu
évidemment ne facilite pas la
l'ouverture
troisième point il sera mon dernier
j'aborderai le la question de la
sécurité vraiment en un mot de
conclusion les transferts de donner à
caractère personnel ça c'est une
spécificité de Tik Tok évidemment ce
sont ces liens avec la Chine la
jurisprudence schremes 2 vous me direz
après si vous souhaitez qu'on y revienne
a fait prendre à la à l'Union européenne
un parti
très stricte sur l'application de loi
étrangère en dehors de l'Union
Européenne qui permettent à des
autorités publiques d'avoir
communication de données de demander à
des opérateurs qui sont soumis à leur
loi de leur communiquer telle ou tel
type de données personnelles pour des
données personnelles qui concernent des
Européens la Cour de justice de l'Union
européenne a demandé que les lois que
les pays qui sont déclarés adéquat par
l'Union européenne n'est pas ce type de
loi ou plus exactement qui les ai en
offrant le répondant au standard de
protection de garantie qui sont ceux
qu'elle exige qui sont exigées pour le
pour l'Union européenne et de ce point
de vue là la loi américaine a été
déclarée
a été déclaré comme ne répondant pas au
standard de protection demandée par la
Cour de justice de l'Union européenne et
dans les dossiers où nous avons croisés
cette question nous avons estimé que le
même constat pouvait être fait avec les
lois chinoises
ça ne veut pas dire et donc ça signifie
que il y a une vigilance particulière à
avoir quand des données à caractère
personnel d'Européens sont transférés
sur le territoire chinois cela signifie
aussi comme la CNIL des peu après la
richrems 2 l'a indiqué qu'il faut faire
attention à des données qui sont entre
les mains d'opérateurs soumis à la
législation chinoise même si ces données
sont hébergées et traitées sur le sol
européen parce que ces données sont
soumises à cette législation par cette
voie indirecte par cette sorte d'effet
rebond de l'arrêt sh 2 et donc peuvent
être soumis au même demande de
communication que si elles étaient sur
le territoire chinois tout ça a été
regardé au cas par cas en fonction des
situations mais c'est un c'est un risque
qui est réel c'est cette question sur
laquelle nous avons notamment à alerté
l'autorité irlandaise c'est à l'autorité
irlandaise de prendre position si une
position qui n'est pas facile à prendre
il faut déterminer dans quelle mesure la
loi chinoise s'applique à telle ou tel
type d'entité du du groupe by dance vous
savez qu'il y a des débats sur ce point
qui se qui sont avancent des arguments
qui sont avancés par Tik Tok il faut
déterminer où sont les données il faudra
aussi déterminer si des mesures
supplémentaires mises en place par
TikTok peuvent ou pas protéger de ce
type de risque si jamais il y avait une
difficulté en revanche la CNIL a encore
plus doctrinal maintenant assez étoffée
pour dire que
il ne suffit pas d'héberger les données
en Europe pour se protéger de ce risque
il faut des mesures de sécurité beaucoup
plus radical beaucoup plus importante
voilà je conclus en disant que comme
vous l'avez vu un certain nombre
d'administrations et notamment depuis
une circulation en France ont décidé de
demander à leur fonctionnaire de ne plus
utiliser TikTok ou plus généralement des
applications récréatives sur leur
téléphone professionnel c'est un
problème qui effectivement me semble
dépasser celui de Tik Tok qui est que
ces applications
accèdent à un certain nombre de choses
sur le téléphone ne sont pas conçus dans
un cadre professionnel et donc avec le
même niveau de sécurité c'est évident et
donc nous n'avons pas pris pour
l'instant la décision similaire à la
CNIL mais nous avons un groupe de
travail en cours pour renforcer
effectivement la sécurité sur nos
terminaux et nous ne pouvons que
soutenir toutes les mesures qui doivent
évidemment être adaptées au contexte de
chaque organisation mais qui essaye de
garantir la confidentialité des données
échangées dans un cadre
professionnel la cybersécurité sur des
terminaux professionnels voilà pour ce
que nous voulions partager avec vous
pour introduire le l'audition
merci Monsieur secrétaire général sur le
rapporteur
merci monsieur le Président merci
Monsieur le Secrétaire général pour
cette exposé introductif
évidemment
nous avons beaucoup de questions à vous
poser je vais commencer par en poser
certaines et mes collègues vont
continuer je n'aurais peut-être d'autres
vous le savez puisque nous avons un
questionnaire mais j'ai bien compris que
une certaine partie des choses nous
serons donnés par vos soins
ultérieurement
pour rebondir sur ce que vous avez dit
en
introduction
alors
ça se sentant particulier au fur et à
mesure des questions que vous avez
posées
à partir du moment où
une partie des compétences de la CNIL a
été transférée sur le régulateur
irlandais
comment se passe
vous êtes vous coordonnez en France avec
un certain nombre d'organismes par
exemple LARCOM etc comment se passe les
choses sur les sujets dont vous avez été
déclaré désormais incompétents comment
se passent les choses entre les autres
organismes qui parcom et vous-même
peut-être sur librairie ça continue et
sur ceux qui sont arrêtés comment ça se
passe avec avec l'Irlande ou est-ce
qu'il y a est-ce qu'il y a pas de
problème ou est-ce que ça peut poser des
problèmes de coordination le deuxième
question que je voudrais vous poser sur
vous avez parlé de l'application qui
était particulièrement je dirais
intrusive en matière de données par
rapport à d'autres à d'autres réseaux
sociaux
première question c'est est-ce que la
collection de données est-ce que vous
avez remarqué si la collection donnée
continue lorsqu'on désactive l'appli
ou est-ce qu'elle est enlevée en même
temps que l'appli est-ce qu'il persiste
dans le téléphone des des
je sais pas quoi des des pixels des des
possibilités de continuer à surveiller
les données
troisième question
je voudrais vous avez terminé ou presque
en disant qu'il y avait évidemment la
nécessité d'une vigilance particulière
lorsque les données sont transférées sur
le territoire chinois ceux qui semblent
être le cas
et que donc des mesures de sécurité plus
importantes sont nécessaires ce qui veut
dire est-ce que vous pouvez me le
confirmer qu'aujourd'hui vous estimez
que la protection n'est pas assurée
puisque c'est ces mesures
n'existent pas ils n'ont pas été prises
de la part de Tik Tok ou en tout cas pas
prise de façon contrôlable
la question suivante
selon la nukibe qui est l'ancien tchèque
le Tik Tok et c'est ce que vous enfin
ils le disent pas comme vous vous dit
qu'il est encore que un nombre important
de donner eux disent qu'il collecte un
nombre excessif de données mais je pense
qu'on est à peu près d'accord là-dessus
je décide pas toutes mais le contenu des
communications privées stocké sur le
serveurs de by dance la vérification
périodique de l'emplacement des
appareils l'accès au contact sur
l'appareil les informations sur
l'appareil le numéro de série le numéro
de téléphone
le numéro de la carte SIM l'accès
permanent au calendrier le navigateur
natif qui d'après la Nuki permet de
surveiller la quasi-totalité de
l'activité de l'utilisateur
[Musique]
la caisse première question c'est est-ce
que vous faites le même constat j'ai
l'impression que oui la deuxième
question c'est cette collecte est-elle
légale ou quelle partie de ses collectes
est-il égal selon vous
et que peut-on que peut-on y faire et
enfin sous réserve de je voudrais pas
être trop long mais sous réserve
d'autres questions tout à l'heure une
question plus générale
vous avez sans doute remarqué comme moi
que l'algorithme de Twitter a été publié
par Elon Musk
il y a quelques jours est-ce qu'on peut
encore accepter les arguments des autres
réseaux sociaux pour refuser de
communiquer les algorithmes qui sont
bien au nœud du problème est-ce que on
peut accepter ces arguments des autres
réseaux sociaux pour ne pas les
communiquer au nom des secrets de
fabrication quel est votre position sur
l'éventuelle demande ou injonction de la
part des des autorités de chaque pays et
ou des autorités européennes de
communication des algorithmes
merci monsieur le sénateur on va essayer
de reprendre les cinq questions et puis
évidemment passer la parole à mes à mes
collègues sur la coordination entre
autorité publique et notamment France
depuis la période du transfert nous
collaborons
parfaitement et très souvent presque
quasi quotidiennement avec l'arcom les
sujets de l'art comme et de la CNIL sont
et vont continuer avec le paquet
numérique européen à être de plus en
plus lié donc dès que l'arcome notamment
doit appliquer des législations à des
contenus il y a des questions de
traitement à donner caractère personnel
et nous avons un dialogue donc continue
pour que tout ça soit fait de façon de
façon fluide alors en revanche vis-à-vis
de l'Irlande là je me tourne Karine je
ne sais pas je suis pas sûr qu'on est
beaucoup de contacts
effectivement
à partir du moment où la l'autorité
pardon est-ce que c'est mieux oui
donc à partir du moment où l'autorité
irlandaise a été compétente
nous avons transmis les éléments
issus de
issus de nos contrôles à l'autorité
irlandaise dans le cadre de la
coopération et depuis lors nous avons
régulièrement depuis
l'été l'été 2020 nous
sollicitons près d'elle assez
régulièrement alors je vais pas dire une
fois par mois mais on a déjà eu au moins
cinq ou six échanges formels dans le
cadre de la coopération formelle qui est
l'article 61 du règlement qui prévoit
qu'on peut faire des des demandes de
tout obtenir toute information utile sur
sur les dossiers donc on leur on leur
demande régulièrement on a fait aussi
des points en fossil ou des points
téléphoniques avec eux pour savoir où en
sont les procédures en question voilà
donc on demande aussi à obtenir de la
documentation celle-ci est
confidentielle mais la documentation sur
ce que la dip ici elle-même réussi à
obtenir de la part de Tik Tok notamment
sur les transferts
on n'a pas entendu la fin de votre
intervention maintenant vous obtenez la
BBC tous les éléments demandés
de la documentation sur ses enquêtes en
cours et notamment sur les transferts
tout ça sous un couvert du
confidentialité évidemment
alors sur la question la collecte
est-elle désactivée quand l'application
est enlevée je ne crois pas que nous
ayons fait de constats au moment donc
début 2020 on a fait des contrôles je
sais pas si Bertrand Payet
peut être ajouté les éléments vous vous
parlez désactivation de la
désinstallation ou
je parle de
je dirais est-ce que la désinstallation
entraîne la désactivation de toutes les
possibilités ou est-ce que il y a des
il y a des
possibilités de recueil de données qui
persiste après désinstallations de
l'application alors comme le secrétaire
général on n'a pas on n'a pas encore
conduit ce type de constat sur les
éventuelles alors il y a deux opérations
on peut constater ce qu'une application
faite ce que le pôle d'expertise
peut-être vous a montré
donc quand elle est activée quels sont
les flux réseaux les
éventuels requêtes qu'elles font sur le
terminal pour accéder à la
géolocalisation au document calendrier
etc on peut constater par ailleurs les
permissions que l'application demande
dans les permissions donc ça c'est ce
qu'elle déclare en fait
avoir besoin ça veut pas dire forcément
qu'elle l'active l'ensemble des
permissions qu'elle demande c'est-à-dire
parmi si elle demande d'avoir accès au
calendrier c'est payant qu'elle passe
son temps à aller chercher l'information
calendrier mais qu'elle demande au
système de d'avoir le droit d'accéder au
calendrier
parmi ces permissions
effectivement dans les permissions si
vous regardez sur un site comme Exodus
prime aussi qui qui vous donne toutes
les permissions d'une application il y a
une application par exemple de relance
automatique
au redémarrage du téléphone qui fait que
l'application en tout cas visiblement
essaye de rester en partie active quand
elle est installée
sans que ça veut dire qu'elle accède à
toutes les autres toutes les autres
dimensions sur la désinstallation donc
quand elle est complètement désinstallé
ce stade nous n'a pas en tout cas on n'a
pas pu regarder encore s'il restait des
processus des bouts de logiciel sur le
système qui resterait installé je tiens
à dire quand même que tous ces systèmes
d'exploitation sont aujourd'hui
maintenant basées sur un système de bac
à sable pour chaque application donc
chaque application est en fait isolée
essaie d'être isolé du reste des autres
applications et du système et de
n'accéder à des informations sur le
terminal que par ce système de
permission qui est dans le cas de Tik
Tok assez large mais
contrôlé par le système donc il est pas
évident en tout cas pour un développeur
normal de de à la désinstallation de
maintenir de maintenir un accès alors
que la pièce
une question qui pour poursuivre vous
avez tout à l'heure parlé monsieur
skateur général de la Ibrah USI et des
demandes d'utilisation de du terminal
est-ce que vous estimez que
les demandes d'utilisation de Tik Tok à
l'utilisateur les demandes de permission
sont aujourd'hui présentées d'une façon
largement compréhensible
claire et
permettant à l'utilisateur de comprendre
ce qu'il fait ou est-ce qu'elle ne le
sont pas assez ou est-ce que sur
certaines elles ne sont pas du tout et
qu'elles sont faites à l'insu de
l'utilisateur
ce qui est assez frustrant pour nous
dans l'exercice c'est que vraiment nous
ne pouvons pas j'ai envie de dire nous
n'avons pas le droit comme ça n'est pas
nous qui sommes compétent et que nous
sanctionnons les opérateurs pour
lesquels nous disons cette collecte de
données est excessive cette information
n'est pas correcte etc vraiment je ne
pouvons pas vous dire que nous trouvons
et je réponds par là aussi à la question
sur la position qui a prise l'ancien
la collecte de données est excessive
nous ne pouvons pas vous dire les
permissions sont excessives la collecte
l'information ne convient pas ce que je
pense nous pouvons dire en tout cas
c'est que par exemple sur l'information
ça fait partie des éléments que nous
avions sur lesquels nous avions
spécifiquement demandé à l'autorité
irlandaise d'enquêter donc nous n'avions
pas qualifié un manquement mais nous
avions estimé que c'était un point qu'il
fallait creuser disons que nous avions
un doute et donc cet élément est dans la
et dans une procédure irlandaise mais
encore une fois on a été arrêté en bout
de quelques mois
et par le transfert enfin par la
création d'un établissement principal et
donc
nous avons aussi arrêté d'investiguer
nous avons des il y a 14000 plaintes qui
arrivent chaque année énormément de gros
opérateurs donc c'est vrai qu'on ne fait
pas beaucoup de constats et de et de
prolongation sur des opérateurs pour
lesquels nous ne sommes pas compétents
ce que nous avons fait c'est ce qui a
rappelé Karine c'est-à-dire tous les
quelques mois de d'abord d'avoir des
contacts informels réguliers avec la
difficile et tout est quelques mois
d'actionner officiellement les
mécanismes du rgpd pour dire où ça en
est il faut que ces deux procédures
avancent
de travailler sur ce sur ce sujet ou
est-ce que ce sujet est transféré en
Irlande et coquins pérennes ou d'autres
organismes ne travaillent aucune
institution de travail sur ce sujet
précis au regard du rgpd aucune autre
institution en France n'a la possibilité
de qualifier le manquement de Tik Tok
ce que font les personnes c'est qui nous
adressent des plaintes où nous nous
déclenchons des investigations enfin des
demandes de notre propre initiative et
nous les passons à l'autorité irlandaise
en revanche évidemment la littérature
elle s'intéresse à ça et ce que vous
dites de l'ancien une partie de la
littérature spécialisée le dit aussi par
ailleurs nous nous avons monté un plan
mais leur plus général pas
spécifiquement sur Tik Tok pour nous
occuper maintenant des applications
mobiles passer du site web aux
applications mobiles il y a l'aspect
cookies qui est une porte d'entrée
notamment parce que voilà la CNIL et
compétences sur tous les acteurs pour
les utilisateur en français mais nous
comptons bien dans ces dans cet exercice
doctrinal donner des précisions plus
précises sur la position de la CNIL
notamment sur les autorisations accès à
la géologue accès au contact et sur
l'information qui doit être donné à ce
moment-là c'est les travaux qui sont en
cours notamment dans la direction de
Bertrand Payet et en disant des choses
plus précises ça permettra aussi de
qualifier un éventuel décalage avec ses
prescriptions pour les opérateurs les
réseaux sociaux dont Tik Tok mais pas
que Tik Tok
peut-être je continue sur la question
chinoise que vous posiez et je vous fais
la même réponse c'est à dire que moi je
ne peux pas vous dire que les que la
protection que les la protection des
données n'est pas assurée ce que je peux
vous dire c'est que la loi la loi
chinoise prit
inabstracto nous cenil nous considérons
qu'elle n'est pas conforme au standard
de la CGE dans l'arrêt shrems 2 ce que
la ces figures à 10 pour la loi
américaine nous estimons que les
autorités de protection doivent le dire
pour la loi chinoise nous nous appuyons
sur une étude que le comité européen la
protection des données a demandé sur la
loi chinoise ce ne sont pas les
conclusions de ce comité européen mais
c'est un document qu'il a mis à
disposition des autorités et des autres
et puis on ça s'appuie sur ce que nous
on a été à regarder nous-mêmes en
revanche après il faut regarder donc
c'est ce que la difficile est en train
de faire avec
Tik Tok et les conseils de la société
Tik Tok si les mesures techniques
juridiques qui ont été mises en place
pour je ne sais pas essayer de
pseudonymiser voire d'anonymiser les
données pour prévoir des bastions de
sécurité pour avoir tel ou tel type de
protection contractualité etc si c'est
protections sont jugées suffisantes ou
non et ça c'est vraiment la difficile
qu'il appartient de le dire et c'est une
des procédures sur lesquelles nous
l'avons régulièrement relancé nous
espérons que un projet de décision
arrivera d'ici l'été
peut-être je vous laisse répondre sur la
publication des algorithmes celui
Twitter et notre position sur cette
question alors nous on n'a pas de
publication sur le sur on n'a pas de
publication on n'a pas de position sur
le sur le la publication des algorithmes
évidemment
alors sans être un spécialiste du droit
de la propriété intellectuelle mais on
peut effectivement considérer que ça
relève du secret industriel Diagon qui
soit utilisé pour pour tout type de
tout type de système ou de ou de
services
le je tiens à dire peut-être deux voilà
dans le dans le cas du secteur public il
y a des obligations de publication qui
font partie en tout cas des des mesures
pour garantir la transparence de
certaines décisions du secteur privé à
ma connaissance il y a pas en tout cas
c'est jamais c'est pas quelque chose
qu'on exige
ça peut avoir comme intérêt
effectivement de pouvoir mieux
comprendre comment fonctionne
l'algorithme il faut aussi avoir en tête
que la publication d'un égoïse c'est
aussi quelque chose qui peut révéler des
des problèmes de sécurité enfin ça
demande c'est une opération qu'il faut
faire avec précaution parce que un
algorithme ouvert c'est un algorithme
qu'on connaît mieux et qu'on peut aussi
plus facilement attaquer donc c'est une
des raisons pour lesquelles on n'a pas
de position de principe sur sur une
telle publication pour les notamment
pour les réseaux sociaux
j'ai une ou deux questions que j'ai vu
monsieur gatelin mais que mes collègues
se signalent pour s'inscrire s'il
souhaite poser des questions d'abord une
un constat vous avez vous-même dit tout
à l'heure que les données collectées
précisément partie toc sont y compris
pour vous qui est baignaient un peu
là-dedans tous les jours et qui avait
perdu votre naïveté depuis longtemps sur
le sujet je cite impressionnant donc
c'est que Tik Tok arrive à vous
impressionner alors que vous connaissez
le un peu le comment dire c'est cuisine
interne habituelles alors mes questions
sont les suivantes vous avez dit que
pouvoir s'assurer de l'emplacement des
données en réalité ne suffit pas et vous
avez dit il faut des mesures plus
radicales il faudrait des mesures plus
radicales la question c'est lesquelles
techniquement
avez-vous si vous pouvez répondre à
cette question était interrogé par le
gouvernement pour savoir s'il était
opportun de prohiber l'installation Tik
Tok et les installations récréatives sur
les téléphones
professionnels des fonctionnaires ce que
vous avez été consulté sur ce sujet
avez-vous de votre point de vue sur
votre champ le champ que vous traitez
vous une explication sur la je vais pas
dire l'emballement mais la concomitance
des interdictions TikTok qui se sont
quand même concentrés dans un laps de
temps assez réduit
il y a eu l'Inde mais ça c'est quand
même accéléré au même moment un peu
partout ce que vous avez une explication
là-dessus ou est-ce que ça relève pas de
votre analyse est-ce que vous nous
conseilleriez à tout hasard
d'auditionner les autorités irlandaises
puisque
vous ne faites pas écran dans la mesure
où il vous donne les informations donc
vous avez besoin mais il y a quand même
des éléments sur lesquels vous nous
dites maintenant nous sommes des saisies
donc devrions-nous
obtiendrions-nous plus d'informations en
auditionnant l'autorité irlandaise
tout à fait de manière incidente
à la commission mais pour savoir quand
même parce que maintenant ce sont les
échanges-vêtements avec les règlements
européens de de façon de travailler vous
travaillez dans quelle langue avec
l'autorité irlandaise comment vous
faites quand vous faites des conférences
téléphoniques ou quand vous vous leur
envoyez des documents est-ce que vous
êtes obligé de les rédiger directement
dans une langue par exemple ou est-ce
que vous leur imposer de travailler en
français
et sur la question de la suppression
question à poser monsieur le rapporteur
vous n'êtes pas en mesure techniquement
de dire si la suppression
empêche le fait qu'il reste des quelques
biscuits par-ci par là ou que le bac à
sable n'est pas totalement fonctionné
parce que ça serait effectivement faire
un procès d'intention mais ce que vous
êtes capable de répondre à cette
question pour d'autres applications par
exemple si vous posez la question pour
Twitter et Facebook est-ce que vous
pouvez dire oui franchement
ou alors vous êtes pas plus avancé
techniquement en tout cas vous n'avez
jamais pris la main dans le sac une
application à laisser des à laisser des
éléments sur le système après après
suppression voilà pour moi et après
monsieur gâteauin ici les collègues se
signaler qui n'hésitent pas
merci beaucoup
donc sur le premier point effectivement
je maintiens les données collectées par
un réseau social tel que Tik Tok son
impressionnantes de de finesse de
rapidité de fréquence j'ajoute aussi que
ça n'est pas le seul c'est-à-dire que à
chaque fois qu'on regarde un peu dans le
détail ce type d'application ce type de
dispositif on est impressionné par le le
type de
de donner qui sont qui sont recueillis
par par ces qui sont voilà
dans la main de l'objet réseau social en
lui-même et de ce qu'on de ce qu'on lui
donne sans sent tellement sans
préoccuper
sur le l'emplacement l'hébergement des
données effectivement c'est une position
que la CNIL a prise rapidement notamment
autour des débats sur le eldes la
création d'un
entrepôt des données de santé avec tout
le système national des données de santé
pour pouvoir
améliorer notamment la recherche à
travers ces données de l'objectif et
vraiment mille fois partagé par là par
la CNIL mais la CNIL a appris
effectivement des positions pour
demander un hébergement entre guillemets
souverain ou de confiance
qui soit immunisé au regard de
l'application de loi extraterritoriales
et de ce point de vue là elle a
considéré qu'à leur même que les
garanties contractuelles obtenues par le
Elsa tape sont assez remarquables en
termes d'hébergement uniquement en
Europe au regard du fait que y compris
pour les opérations d'administration de
mise à jour du système tout cela n'est
opéré qu'en Europe et bien le seul fait
que le serveur soit entre les mains d'un
opérateur qui est soumis à la loi
américaine également le place dans une
situation de conflit de législation il
est soumis au rgpd et aux lois
européenne puisque le serveur est
effectivement en Europe et le rgpd lui
dit qu'il ne peut pas communiquer les
données mais il est aussi soumis à la
loi de son siège à la loi américaine qui
lui prévoit des possibilités de
communication de données comme ça existe
dans tous les pays du monde mais la loi
américaine dans la rescherems 2 a été
jugé pour le moment maintenant il y a un
exécutif order qui a changé la situation
depuis quelques mois la Commission est
en train de se pencher sur cette
question mais qui avait été jugé non
conforme au standard européen donc il y
a bien cette idée que si vous êtes en
Europe mais opéré par une entreprise qui
se trouve par ailleurs soumise à une loi
extraterritoriale il faut regarder de
façon réaliste communication de cette
loi extraterritoriale et à ce moment là
les protections à obtenir sont
effectivement assez radicales il faut
soit les deux grandes familles c'est
soit les données sont entièrement
chiffrées et manipuler uniquement à en
étant chiffré ce qui dès qu'on fait des
choses un petit peu délicates mais ça
Bertrand soleil plus précisant que moi
devient très difficile voire parfois
impossible soit il faut avoir un
opérateur qui est qui est immunisée qui
n'est pas soumis à ce type de loi donc
soit il est entièrement européen soit
des systèmes qui sont en train de se
monter sur lesquels les les
partenariats notamment avec des grandes
sociétés américaines se sont montées
pour avoir une manipulation des données
par un opérateur européen sur lequel
s'ajoutent une couche logicielle qui
elle appartient à un opérateur
extra-européen donc c'est ce type de
protection que nous nous avons eu à
rencontrer ou à envisager jusqu'ici
vous m'avez demandé si le gouvernement
nous avait interrogé avant de
prendre la une circulaire pour demander
que certaines applications récréatives
ne soient pas utilisées sur les
téléphones professionnels le
gouvernement n'a pas saisi
officiellement la CNIL nous n'avons pas
eu d'opération de discussion officielle
en revanche moi j'ai eu un appel
informel de quelqu'un pour voilà savoir
si du côté de la CNIL il y avait une
objection particulière ou un besoin de
la saisir particulière encore une fois
pour nous c'est véritablement une
décision à prendre par chaque
gouvernement ou peut-être aussi
entreprises etc en fonction de la cible
de la sécurité de ces de ces matériels
c'était pas une position à prendre par
la par la d'ailleurs dans les autres
pays c'est aussi vous la Commission
européenne c'est aussi ce qui s'est ce
qui s'est passé
le
oui vous me demandez si j'avais une
explication sur la concomitance des des
interdictions de par le monde je n'en ai
pas effectivement je trouve que
l'approche qui a été prise par le
gouvernement français qui si je la
comprends bien est une approche qui
n'est pas non plus centrée que sur Tik
Tok mais sur une des classes
d'applications qui d'abord présente la
particularité d'être récréatif donc pas
professionnelle de d'avoir besoin de
beaucoup d'accès à des données y compris
sans rentrer dans le débat sur excessif
ou pas excessif elle le fait elles ont
besoin de consommer beaucoup de données
donc du coup ça expose plus de risques
et puis elles sont conçues avec des
niveaux de de sécurité qui qui sont ceux
d'applications et pas forcément de
matériel professionnel je pense c'est la
bonne approche de ne l'avoir pas centré
sur TikTok maintenant je constate que
effectivement tout autour du monde d'une
un mouvement spécifique sur sur Tik Tok
à a eu lieu
alors sur la langue dans laquelle on
est-ce que nous vous ne me conseillez
vous de vous conseiller d'auditionner
l'autorité irlandaise
je
pense que ce serait logique
je voilà après je ne sais pas ce qui
s'estimeraient être en
droit mesures de vous dire de ne pas
vous dire mais moi je le vous je trouve
ce serait assez logique et ce serait le
pendant de du fait que nous arrivons
devant vous en vous disant que depuis
2020 sur un certain nombre de sujets
nous ne sommes plus compétents et donc
la masse d'essuie donc voilà je trouve
que ce serait logique alors est-ce qu'on
travaille uniquement en anglais avec la
difficile et au comité et au Comité
européen la protection des données de
fait les choses se font en anglais
effectivement en anglais avec la avec
l'autorité irlandaise également dans les
dans les groupes de travail au CEPD on
travaille également en anglais mais
quand on reçoit enfin on reçoit des
plaintes en français on les fait
traduire en anglais pour les envoyer à
notre homologue voilà
les applications sachant que pour sur la
suppression d'une appli pour d'autres
applications sachant que les autres
applications que vous avez cité Facebook
Twitter etc je crois en toute également
le rétablissement principal à en Irlande
donc mais ça ne veut pas dire qu'on ne
peut pas le faire pour d'autres paysans
mais c'est pour vous donner la mesure du
fait que sur ces grandes applications
c'est grosses la compétence est vraiment
concentrée en Irlande par l'application
du rgpd
donc sur donc ce que j'ai ce que j'ai pu
lire sur le fait de savoir ce qui
restait comme de l'application une fois
qu'elle a été désinstallée
donc en fait
je peux faire la même réponse pour les
autres en fait à ce stade je peux pas
vous dire Facebook c'est ok on a tout
vérifié on
est on est au stade comme comme l'a dit
le secrétaire général sur la question
les applications mobiles on est en train
de préparer une une position une
recommandation qui précisera vraiment
qu'est-ce qu'on attend des applications
notamment des briques logiciels qui
s'appellent les SDK dans les
applications enfin de tous les tous les
acteurs et suite à ça on pourra conduire
des investigations qui permettront de
voir des choses mais pas forcément
devoir devoir tout et donc on n'a pas un
état spécifique pour pour Tik Tok par
rapport à d'autres en tout cas dont on
en dehors des des
éventuels procédures dont on qui ne sont
pas et qui relève pas de ma direction je
dois dire deux une chose en plus c'est
que je vois juste rappeler aussi que la
suppression de l'application ne supprime
pas les évidemment de ne supprime pas ce
qui est associé à votre compte sur le
sur les serveurs de Tik Tok donc ce qui
par ailleurs et d'autres d'autres
manières de pour l'éditeur de la du
logiciel de conserver des informations
que vous aviez pu lui transmettre quand
l'application était active
si vous me permettez monsieur le
Président par rapport à ce que vous
disiez tout à l'heure générale vous
parlez des conflits de législation en
fonction de la
localisation de la plateforme qui qui
opèrent directement et sa maison mère
Tik Tok est une SAS enregistrée en
France mais c'est une filiale de by
dance qui est enregistrée aux îles
Caïmans
donc ma question est la suivante est-ce
que vous considérez qu'ils sont que Big
Dogg est soumise à cette double
législation
ou est-ce que Tik Tok c'est en France et
un point c'est tout et donc elle doit
répondre intégralement sans pouvoir
exciter de la législation des îles
Caïmans qui sur ce plan peut-être assez
particulière
alors sur le contrôle de Karine les deux
à la fois c'est à dire qu'on considère
que si TikTok donc pour la partie qui
est en France qui est encore une fois je
crois ne s'occupe que de la
commercialisation enfin une activité
très très périphérique par rapport à ce
qui nous occupe aujourd'hui mais cette
société est en France et elle est soumis
à la législation française et c'était un
peu un point c'est tout mais en revanche
dans
la question de la protection des données
et de la possibilité pour des entités
quelque part ailleurs sur la planète de
pouvoir se les faire communiquer et
ensuite c'est pas forcément interdit
mais on regarde si c'est proportionné si
c'est fait sous le contrôle d'un juge
etc etc pour ça on a la CNIL a pris une
approche réaliste c'est à dire on ne
s'arrête pas au fait que on a créé une
filiale en Europe pour dire ah bah il y
a plus de problème la filiale est en
Union Européenne non si la filiale est
entièrement contrôlée par quelqu'un qui
est par une par un groupe une maison
mère aux îles Caïmans aux États-Unis en
Chine n'importe où on regarde si les
législations de ces pays-là peuvent
obliger la maison mère à répondre à une
demande de communication une autre forme
d'injonction qu'elle serait obligée de
répercuter à la filiale qu'elle contrôle
avec une obligation généralement
d'ailleurs de confidentialité et de ne
pas le dire et donc dans ces cas-là oui
on tient compte du fait que il peut y
avoir une soumission un peu indirecte
via la via la maison mère à une
législation extra-européenne
alors Monsieur gâteauin et après madame
billon madame Bourrat s'il y en a
d'autres faites-moi signe oui merci
monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Secrétaire général mesdames messieurs
évidemment beaucoup de questions vous
avez évoqué que la Nil était le
dessinateur de plainte
alors c'est pas non plus la plateforme
pharoz donc vous recueillez vous
recueillez la crème de la crème des
plaintes c'est quoi le volume des
plaintes la nature on a bien compris que
c'était pas sur les contenus et quel
volume dans ces plaintes concernant les
réseaux ou autres concernent TikTok ça
c'est la première question
deuxième question vous l'avez évoqué la
règle de deux et de durée de stockage
des données est-ce que
où en sommes-nous en gros nous sommes
quand même sur un réseau social qui vise
des publics jeunes qui sont amenés à
grandir et peut-être un petit peu moins
transgressif le risque réputationnel si
on stocke des données au
delà de 50 dix ans c'est de se retrouver
dans des gens qui un jour peut avoir une
position sociale et faire l'objet de
certaines pressions ça donc qu'est-ce
qui régit cette durée de conservation
des données
vous avez évoqué que vous n'avez pas été
quand même formellement consulté sur les
décisions prises par le gouvernement et
heureusement parce que
autant je partage le caractère
agnostique autant je comprends pas le
choix qui a été fait notamment quand on
va opérer on nous explique que Netflix
n'est pas un réseau social il exclut de
leur réflexion ils mettent Amazon parce
que il y a du traitement enfin si c'est
l'usage récréatif qu'on vise c'est
vraiment
d'accord mais tout le monde n'y est pas
enfin bon la mesure quand même ça fait
un peu la forêt la petite forêt le
bosquet qui essaye de cacher le séquoia
c'est-à-dire qu'on vise TikTok sans dire
aux autorités chinoises qu'on visite
TikTok en faisant ça ça c'est une
analyse enfin un point de vue personnel
par ailleurs là j'ai été co-rapporteur
sur l'état actuel du Règlement sur
l'intelligence artificielle donc au
Sénat on se pose beaucoup de questions
sur
l'application du rgpd à l'IA parce que
on a beau règlement rgpd on n'est pas
sûr au regard d'ailleurs de la
législation telle qu'elle est écrite
mais qui est quand même assez avancé
puisqu'on arrive au trilogue qu'elle
préserve
lequel préserve les règles du rgpd on
sait que Tik Tok devient le champion de
l'utilisation de l'intelligence
artificielle dans les réseaux sociaux
donc est-ce que il faudrait pas penser
avant même qu'on émette je dirais
définitivement cette ce règlement a
renforcé le lien et entre guillemets sa
soumission directe au rgpd et puis au
dernier élément mais c'est très
secondaire c'est que
Tik Tok développe beaucoup de nouvelles
applications dérivées type lemonate qui
commence à bien marcher aux États-Unis
est-ce que ce sont des créations
exténillons ou est-ce qu'il y a
utilisation de potentiellement
utilisation de données recueillies via
le navire amiral qui est Tik Tok pour
lancer et développer parce
qu'aujourd'hui on en est à cinq ou six
applications dérivées qui sont lancés
tous azimut notamment bien sûr pas sur
le marché chinois mais sur le marché
américain et qui devrait être bientôt
aussi débarqué dans l'Union européenne
donc est-ce que vous avez des
informations à ce sujet je vous remercie
on va peut-être essayer de grouper des
questions mais en prenant le temps de la
réponse donc Madame billon merci
monsieur le Président merci messieurs
madame pour déjà les réponses aux
nombreuses questions que vous avez eu on
a parlé de conflits de législation
est-ce que vous pourriez nous donner des
pistes d'évolution de la législation
actuelle qui permettrait de s'adapter
finalement au changement permanent qui
opère finalement des nouvelles
applications comme bien de le mentionner
André catholin c'est c'est
récurrent donc c'est ce qu'on est
suffisamment paré et sur la CNIL moi je
voudrais savoir puisqu'il a été question
d'investigation est-ce que vous estimez
avoir suffisamment de moyens
d'investigation suffisamment de moyens
humains et suffisamment de prérogatives
pour pouvoir
finalement répondre à tous les enjeux de
sécurité de protection de données qui
sont finalement au cœur de nos
préoccupations donc est-ce que vous avez
besoin aussi finalement de plus de
moyens est-ce qu'il est question d'un
sermenter plus de personnels quels sont
les outils juridiques que vous pourriez
imaginer pour s'adapter à cette à cet
écosystème en mouvement permanent je
vous remercie
merci monsieur le Président
alors moi ma question est la suivante
nous sommes tous d'accord pour
nous dire que les données collectées
sont impressionnantes vous l'avez dit
tout à l'heure vous nous avez aussi
indiqué que on considérait que la
collecte des données était faite avec
l'accord de l'utilisateur donc sachant
que cette application que la cible de
cette application est un public jeune
voire très jeune et donc vulnérable
sachant que cette application est aussi
une application addictive je voudrais
savoir si la CNIL considère que donc
suite à la mise à jour des conditions
d'utilisation qui arrivent régulièrement
le fait qu'un mineur valide les
nouvelles conditions d'utilisation
est-ce que la CNIL considère donc la
collecte des données des mineurs est
légales
je vous en prie
merci beaucoup alors pour commencer par
le sujet des plaintes le rgpd est passé
d'un système où il y avait 100 000
déclarations autorisation à soit par la
CNIL un système excenté un système de
plainte expost on en a entre 12000 et
14000 par an le premier défi que nous
avons c'est d'arriver à répondre à
toutes ces plaintes qui sont d'une
variété d'une variété
extraordinaire et
c'est vrai que c'est pas du tout les
volumes de pharose mais en même temps ça
n'est pas non plus du tout la crème de
la crème c'est à dire nous avons des
choses qui vont avoir été faites par des
avocats ou pour une association
extrêmement et puis après quelqu'un qui
n'y connaît rien cette législation est
très abstraite et il faut il faut
l'aider il faut comprendre ce qu'il dit
parfois ça n'est pas du tout du ressort
de la CNIL cela juge peut lui donner ce
qu'il souhaite donc nous avons vraiment
une variété et dans ces plaintes qui est
très très forte alors plus
spécifiquement sur les réseaux sociaux
et Tik Tok je vais laisser Karine
Kieffer vous donner quelques éléments
présente vraiment très très peu de
plaintes puisqu'on en a en ce moment six
en cours ce qui est très peu pour faire
un comparatif avec méta c'est à peu près
une centaine de plein de chaque année
donc c'est ça représente peu c'est sans
doute ça s'explique sans doute par le
fait que les que le public qui utilise
le plus Tik Tok est un public de mineur
et que nous avons globalement tout
secteurs confondus très peu de plein de
mineurs à peine 1% des mêmes parts même
pas 1% des des plantes que nous que nous
recevons viennent de mineurs et nous
sommes d'ailleurs en train de travailler
assez question à la CNIL avec plusieurs
directions pour essayer de réfléchir à
notre parcours de plainte en ligne et
puis voir si
si une meilleure présentation de la CNIL
et du parcours de plantes pourraient
encourager les les adolescents à plus
nous saisir mais un gros travail qui est
fait aussi dans les dans les écoles dans
les collèges pour les sensibiliser à ces
questions puisque si il faut qu'ils
connaissent la CNIL et qui viennent sur
notre site mais encore faut-il qu'ils
aient l'information sur nos sur nos
pouvoirs et sur nos compétences voilà
donc si pleines donc c'est très peu dont
la majorité dont cinq plaintes qui
partent à la difficile autoritaire
irlandaise une seule plante que nous
traitons directement en application de
la loi Informatique et Liberté qui a une
disposition particulière pour les pour
les demandes d'effacement qui sont
adressées quand la personne était mineur
sur au moment de la collecte de ces
données et donc dans ce cas précis c'est
la CNIL qui intervient directement au
titre de l'article 51 la loi de la loi
Informatique et Liberté et si et peut
obtenir la l'effacement des données de
la personne qui était mineure sous trois
semaines voilà donc c'est excusez-moi
qu'est-ce qui vaut c'est l'âge déclaré
ou l'âge réel parce qu'on sait que sur
Tik Tok les adolescents voir les enfants
donnent un âge beaucoup plus important
donc Tik Tok peut dire ben cette
personne m'a dit qu'elle avait 18 ans
alors que elle en avait 12 donc
qu'est-ce qui vaut c'est la réalité de
l'âge ou pas
alors la loi ne le précise pas il est
dit qu'il faut que la personne soit
mineure au moment de la collecte et
comme nous n'avons qu'une plainte nous
sommes en train de regarder pour voir
comment la traiter mais effectivement
vous soulevez un
sujet qui est tout à fait juste sur le
fait que aujourd'hui nous nous avons
fait dans le cadre des contrôles et
vérifications de
pour saisir notre notre date de
naissance et effectivement
vous avez potentiellement des des
enfants qui peuvent qui peuvent mentir
sur la rage sachant qu'il y a comme on a
quand même constaté un aspect positif
lors des contrôles c'est qu'on avait
rentré un âge fictif en contrôlant en
ligne
prétendant que nous avions 12 ans et
nous étions bloqués et nous avions
rentré ensuite l'âge de une date de
naissance qui correspondait à 1978
l'année de la CNIL et nous étions encore
bloqué pourquoi parce que Tik Tok vous
bloque vous bloque si vous rentrez deux
dates de naissance différentes dans la
même heure TikTok vous bloque voilà donc
une précaution qui a été prise par le
par le réseau social
vous m'interrogez sur les la règle de
durée de conservation notamment pour le
stockage des données pour les pour les
réseaux sociaux
pour le coup je pense que c'est sont des
raisonnements assez classiques de la loi
informatique et liberté ou du règlement
que nous avons l'habitude de tenir c'est
à dire que la durée de conservation se
regarde par finalité par paquet de
finalité donc tant que le compte est
actif la
durée de conservation est assez
largement admise parce que le contrat
est en cours le service est en cours en
revanche
le jour où vous supprimez votre compte
l'application que vous Vous désinscrivez
du réseau social à mon sens la plupart
des données notamment toutes les données
de profilage utilisé pour par exemple
présenter des vidéos devrait être
supprimés toutes les données ne sont pas
supprimées ça c'est le cas dans pour
tous les opérateurs qui ont des contrats
avec des avec des tiers généralement ils
gardent un certain nombre de données
pour
diverses finalité certaines d'ailleurs
sont des obligations légales de garder
pendant un certain temps la trace du
fait que vous aviez un compte avec telle
personne un contrat etc avec des durées
qui sont généralement calées sur les
durées de prescription ou un peu
augmenté si jamais il y a des causes
d'interruption possible sur des choses
assez classiques nous
recommandons et parfois nous exigeons
que quand les données vont être gardées
à certains nombre d'années et présentent
encore une certaine sensibilité elle
soit placée dans ce qu'on appelle une
archive intermédiaire pour qu'elle soit
structurellement fonctionnellement
séparés du des autres des autres
serveurs
sur le règlement il y a et son
articulation avec le rgpd peut-être le
Bertrand je vous laisse la parole
sur sur ce point
sur ce point alors nous on a constaté
c'est que je crois qu'on avait dit
dans les travaux de votre commission on
avait on avait constaté en fait d'une
complémentarité entre les deux
règlements puisque le règlement rgpd
concerne les responsables de traitement
donc des entreprises qui mettent en
place des des algorithmes informatiques
et règlement idéal concerne les
fournisseurs de solutions donc les gens
en fait qui vont offrir la brique en
l'occurrence d'intelligence artificielle
il nous semble que ça vient donc ces
acteurs qu'on a indirectement en fait
par le rgpd donc le règlement il y a
permettra de leur imposer les
obligations directes sur leur position
de base d'apprent leur donner
d'apprentissage par exemple ou les
mesures de biais donc ils sont des
mesures qu'on peut pas forcément
aujourd'hui imposer directement en
lecture de rgpd même si on est en train
de travailler sur ces questions là sur
quels sont les obligations dérivées du
rgpd à ces acteurs là
donc on voilà on pense que ça pourra
compléter entre guillemets la
réglementation tout en
reconnaissant que dans l'architecture à
risque de du règlement Ia les dia pour
des applications récré récréatives ne
sont pas forcément identifiées comme des
applications à haut risque qui sont
soumis du coup à des obligations
renforcées le souhait étant de étant de
évidemment de ne pas empêcher des
innovations fondées sur ce type
d'algorithmes
sur les nouvelles applications de Tik
Tok sont-elles faites en utilisant des
données de Tik Tok alors évidemment je
peux pas vous répondre sur ce que ce que
fait exactement Tik Tok mais je peux
vous dire là encore sur le contrôle de
mes voisins la façon dont je pense que
nous aborderions le la question on
constate quand même souvent dans les
politiques de confidentialité donc dans
la notice avec les informations sur
qu'est-ce qu'on va faire des données
qu'on se retrouve à traiter dans le
cadre d'un service quel qu'il soit on
constate souvent dans ces politiques de
confidentialité des formules très vagues
sur le fait que les données sont
utilisées pour améliorer votre
expérience utilisateur vous donner plus
de confort etc et puis un moment se
glisse
améliorer nos services à notre service
nos services alors nous nous savons
enfin sous le contrôle de mes voisins
que derrière ces finalités là c'est ça
qui se cache c'est à dire c'est le fait
que
une société et là on parle pas que de
Tik Tok toutes les sociétés souhaitent
faire ça elles souhaitent utiliser les
données qu'elles ont de leur expérience
commerciale avec leurs clients pour
faire de la R&D pour
avoir des nouveaux dispositifs et c'est
d'ailleurs dans une certaine partie
aussi dans une certaine mesure légitime
donc nous nous abordons d'abord
la question d'un point de vue de règle
de protection des données sur
l'information je dois comprendre que
c'est pas uniquement pour mon confort
d'utilisateur que la donnée est utilisée
mais c'est pour la R&D de la société
c'est pas interdit mais ça doit être dit
et c'est généralement un traitement dont
nous estimons qui repose sur le
consentement quand le traitement de
d'utilisation des données de R&D
intimement indissociablement liés de ce
que fait la société par exemple pour
repérer je donne un cas un peu
caricatural mais des bugs de sécurité
dans le voilà nous estimons que ça peut
être sur l'intérêt légitime parfois de
la société que ces traités donc intérêt
légitime c'est la façon dont dans notre
texte rgpd on va dire pas de
consentement je fais je suis légitime à
le faire sans vous demander votre accord
et en revanche si c'est pour faire
quelque chose de complètement différent
nous orientons plutôt et nous estimons
dans un certain nombre de cas qu'il est
obligatoire d'avoir le consentement de
la personne donc c'est la façon dont on
aborderait je pense cette question si on
devait interroger déjà TikTok sur est-ce
que vous utilisez les les données pour
les autres appliques vous développez et
ensuite regarder si c'est oui est-ce que
c'est bien fait voilà notamment s'il y a
un consentement en principe les
consentements doivent pouvoir se donner
de façon
libre et donc distinctes par sinon par
finalité au moins par ensemble de
finalité connexes et donc ça c'est une
assez distincte
voilà alors sur le conflit de
législation c'est une question qu'on
rencontre assez souvent
qui n'est pas un problème en soi je
pense et c'est à dire que c'est aussi le
revers du fait que le rgpd a une
dimension
extraterritoriale
cette dimension nous pensons qu'elle est
bonne c'est à dire nous pensons que il
faut effectivement que des opérateurs
qui sont à l'autre bout du monde qui
n'ont pas d'établissement
en Europe donc dont l'activité n'est pas
territorialisable en Europe soit quand
même soumis au rgpd si ils sont en train
de traiter des données de citoyens
européen d'une manière qui évidemment
tout est dans d'une manière qui les les
relis à la vie privée des citoyens
européens donc la CNIL a pris dans le
sillage d'autres
les autorités récemment une une décision
sur une société clairview qui a utilisé
toutes les photographies publiquement
disponibles sur le sur le web pour créer
des gabarits biométriques donc quelque
chose qui permet à un système de
reconnaissance faciale de pouvoir vous
identifier de façon extrêmement efficace
avec un taux d'erreur qui va en tout cas
quand le gabarit est bon peut être
vraiment très faible évidemment sans
consentement n'est rien etc la société
n'a aucune aucun lien avec l'Europe
voilà et donc elle se retrouve dans un
situation de conflit de législation
puisque elle était soumis à une
législation américaine et tout d'un coup
on vient lui voir la voir en lui disant
ah mais en fait vous êtes aussi soumis
au rgpd évidemment avec des arguments en
réponse de la société de 10 ans mais
c'est très très difficile comment
voulez-vous que je distingue sur
internet si j'ai une photographie de
quelqu'un du Texas ou de quelqu'un
d'Italie donc il y a un moment où je
vais venir on assume le conflit de
législation et le fait que le rgpd voilà
va déborder va déborder du territoire à
l'inverse évidemment du coup il faut le
gérer quand ce sont des législations
étrangères
extraordinaire de l'Union européenne qui
viennent aussi de fait s'appliquer sur
des choses qui se passent sur le sur le
territoire français et je pense que en
en tirant des conséquences la CNIL a été
vraiment dans la lignée de l'arracherems
2 donc la réponse comment adapter ça je
pense c'est moins dans des modifications
de la législation pour essayer de
minimiser voire de supprimer tout
recoupement entre les
extra-territorialités parce que les
législations de pays en dehors de
l'Union Européenne continueront à être
par certains aspects extra-territorial
donc nous ne ferions que renoncer d'une
certaine manière à ce que le rgpd a
commencé à faire en revanche je pense
qu'il faut proportionner
le la réponse qu'on en fait c'est à dire
que c'est très difficile à gérer pour
les acteurs c'est recoupements de
législation où ils se retrouvent une
entreprise se retrouve à devoir
conjuguer le rgpd une loi américaine le
rgpd lois chinoise le rgpd une loi d'un
autre pays c'est très difficile donc je
pense qu'il faut avoir une demander
l'application enfin faire jouer le
conflit jusqu'au bout donc en disant du
coup c'est pas possible ce que vous me
disiez mais juste comment on va bah du
coup on a plus un opérateur
extra-européen ou alors il faut avoir ce
système très très difficile à mettre en
place de claques de confiance il faut
aller jusque là quand ces proportionné
c'est à dire quand les données qui sont
derrière en valent le coup
est-ce que l'acné la suffisamment de
moyens je vais répondre non
merci oui de la CNIL a demande depuis
trois quatre ans beaucoup beaucoup de
moyens on envoie des notes
à Bercy qui qui font faire un infarctus
la personne de la direction du budget
qu'il est qui les lie parce que on a
demandé vraiment énormément
de moyens il y a 3 ans on a vraiment un
peu tirer la sonnette d'alarme on a dit
mais on va absolument pas y arriver on
avait des taux de on avait des taux
parce que c'est maintenant c'est un peu
plus stabilisé de 30% de croissance des
plaintes de 30% de croissance des
plaintes d'une année sur l'autre c'est
juste absolument ingérable et dans le
même temps en réalité cette ce système
de plainte n'a pas du tout déchargé la
la
nécessité pour la Cnil d'anticiper de
faire des recommandations des lignes
directrices d'aller regarder d'aller
fouiller les plaintes vont concerner
pour des milliers et des milliers et des
milliers de plaintes la même chose je
n'ai pas pu accéder à mes données je
n'arrive pas à effacer mes données des
choses c'est les milliers de cas comme
ça et en revanche on n'a pas une plainte
qui est venu nous dire j'ai enlevé mon
application et j'ai l'impression que il
y a encore des données c'est parce que
c'est extraordinairement subtil
j'imagine pour capter les indices qui
font ça donc il faut à la fois qu'on
traite les plaintes qu'on est là la
capacité de sécuriser les acteurs par
des lignes directrices et des
recommandations et les fédérations
professionnelles nous en demande
toujours plus en nous disant vous me
dites que je suis je peux avoir des
sanctions jusqu'à 4% du chiffre
d'affaires mondial d'accord mais sortez
un papier pour me dire comment ça
s'applique le rgpd à tel type de
situation et donc c'est assez difficile
pour nous de satisfaire tout le monde et
de garder une capacité d'enquête de
veille indépendamment de tout ça voilà
donc on a obtenu et on en remercie le
Parlement des moyens la CNIL a vraiment
grossi elle atteindra elle se
rapprochera des 300 agents à la fin de
cette année et elle devrait normalement
dans les quatre années prochaines
continuer à croître sur une tendance
plus
faible mais qui qui vraiment nous a
permis de faire des de faire des choses
et il y avait une dernière question oui
sur l'accord pour la mise à jour des
conditions d'utilisation est-il légal
c'est une question qu'on rencontre assez
fréquemment je crois je sais pas si vous
voulez la prendre
en fait les mineurs la base légale de la
base légale du traitement des données
des mineurs selon Tik Tok c'est le
contrat donc effectivement
à partir de 13 ans qui est l'âge
autorisé pour Tik Tok à pour que des
mineurs puissent s'inscrire il TikTok
laisse les mineurs de 13 ans et plus
signés ces conditions s'inscrire et
signer ces conditions générales
considérant que c'est le contrat qui qui
est la base légale du 10 traitement des
données et ça fait partie des justement
des des sujets qui avaient été vérifiés
lors de nos contrôles ce point-ci est
aussi le fait que les les données des
mineurs étaient aussi rendus publics par
défaut quand il s'inscrivait leur profil
était public par défaut donc des
questions de protection de mineur
effectivement qui ont été transférées à
la difficile autorité irlandaise et qui
soulève vraiment la question de la
capacité du mineur de 13 ans à accepter
ces
conditions générales
et peut-être pour compléter sur un point
là aussi on sait on touche aux droits
contractuel il y a souvent un problème
d'articulation quand on a un contrat
entre le droit de la protection des
données personnelles et le droit
contractuel le mineur signe un contrat
il faut qu'il ait la capacité
contractuelle quand est-ce qu'il l'a
quand est-ce qu'il ne l'a pas et pour
les questions de mise à jour des
conditions générales c'est une question
très classique en droit contractuel donc
ça n'est pas interdit par principe ça
n'est pas toujours permis non plus et
évidemment on a cette difficulté que nos
utilisateurs ils sont français c'est en
partie vous faites la commission
d'enquête ou pas aussi pour les pollets
pour les jeunes Français qui utilisent
Tik Tok c'est la quinil qui irlandaise
qui est compétente avec une loi du
contrat qui est irlandaise quelle est la
loi du contrat qui s'applique donc Tik
Tok mets des choses dans ces dans ces
contrats etc et donc on tombe sur des
questions contractuelles qui sont peu
résolues peu peu détaillées par le par
le rgpd sur lesquels on n'a pas encore
de jurisprudence des juridiction tions
de position de position très claire et
qui sont évidemment
assez assez délicate
poursuivre la question sur la les moyens
on a parlé des moyens de la CNIL mais
moi je me pose des questions sur les
moyens de la dépiti
est-ce que la difficile dispose de
moyens suffisants puisqu'elle s'est vu
qu'elle reconfiait une bonne partie des
compétences décnils de toute l'Europe
alors je pense que vous allez pas me
dire même si vous le pensez que la
difficile n'a pas les moyens suffisant
je vais pas vous poser cette question
mais je voudrais vous poser la question
est-ce que vous savez de combien
d'agents vous dites que vous êtes près
de 300 juste pour l'acné le française
dans un pays est-ce que vous pouvez nous
dire
quel est le l'effectif de la DBC en
Irlande pour gérer une bonne partie des
dossiers européens et je voudrais vous
poser une deuxième question est-ce qu'un
recours devant le Conseil d'État a été
formé par la décision de pour la
décision la CNIL du 22 du 29 décembre
et est-ce que Tik Tok depuis a changé
ses pratiques dans le domaine des
cookies que vous avez évoqué
alors sur le nombre d'agents on va vous
envoyer cette information je ne sais pas
vous le dire au débotté nous l'avons
puisque je l'ai lu dans des dans des
notes et il a notamment nettement
augmenté c'est à dire les moyens de la
déplition était renforcés et je vous
laisserai donc on vous donnera le
chiffre et on vous laissera évidemment
apprécier s'ils sont suffisant ou pas à
ma connaissance la décision tikloque
n'est pas attaquée devant le Conseil
d'État alors est-ce qu'elle est
définitivement doit se rapprocher du
moment où elle est définitive puisque ça
a été notifié début janvier ah oui il y
a un délai de distance donc c'est 4 mois
donc l'édition n'est pas encore
définitive et pour l'instant elle n'est
pas attaquée à notre connaissance devant
le Conseil d'État ciel si elle l'avait
été ce serait vraiment très récent et on
n'aurait pas encore eu la le
l'information du du greffe et est-ce que
Tik Tok a changé ses pratiques donc
c'était une enquête qui partait sur le
site web et oui elles ont été chargées
avant même d'ailleurs la fin de la
procédure sur votre contrôle
les pratiques avaient été améliorées
merci merci beaucoup du temps que vous
nous avez consacré